John Lewis Gaddis author of surprise
security and the American experience if
someone picks up this small 150 page
book what's in it hmm I think there's
some history in it I think there's some
current events in it and there's some
thinking about the future in it and I
hope that there's some connection
between these things because it's
intended to be a book about September
11th it's also intended to be a book
about previous American experiences with
surprise attack of which there have been
a couple but it's also an effort to try
to think through where we go from here
to the future where were you on
September the 11th I was where I
described in the first chapter of this
book I was giving a PhD oral examination
at Yale and we had just gone into the
examination room when the word came that
something had happened at the Trade
Center our student was a Vietnamese
American student who had fled Vietnam a
quarter century earlier with her family
and it's her most critical moment of her
entire graduate career so three of us
are in the room with her sequestered in
the period between 9:30 and 11:30 on
that morning not wanting to tell her
what had happen sneaking out to try to
get information ourselves about what had
happened if she did find and she passed
and then we told her at 11:30 what had
happened and she said I knew I just
hadn't wanted to upset the three of you
so that's right wasn't subject what was
your reaction to all that but but did
that mean much to you it was
extraordinarily frustrating in one sense
to know that something disastrous was
happening outside not to know the scale
of it not to know how big it was or
where else the hijackers we didn't even
know they were hijackers for sure at
that point I'd have to concentrate on
doing a PhD exam but I think it was also
very important to concentrate on that
because it was important to finish that
up even though we knew we were coming
out of that examination room into a
different world and almost the whole
event kind of symbolized September 11th
forming because there was absolute shock
and abnormality of the event but this
was combined with the sense that life
to go on and one has to try to
reconstruct normality in this process
both of these things were happening on
that morning with this one event well as
you thought back on it did it have any
impact on that this was a Vietnamese
American absolutely because the time
with the history the tie-in with the
hope that this country has for people
who were born overseas and grow up
overseas and want to come to this
country was very much in my mind and I
say at the end of the book that in a way
that's what the hijackers were after
they were trying to destroy that hope
that the country stands for
so there really was had a connection in
that sense in my mind what was the PhD
candidates thesis about her thesis is on
the international history of the Vietnam
War in the last five years of it and
she's fluent and Vietnamese so I was
able to use Vietnamese sources American
sources British sources so it will be an
international history of the diplomacy
surrounding the end of the Vietnam War
from roughly the time that Nixon came in
to the Paris peace at almost 30 years
how old is this woman she is about 34 so
the lecture series that that yes but
this book came from how did that happen
the lecture series is the joini jackson
goldman lecture series at the New York
Public Library and this came about
really the series had been in the works
before but the my particular series of
lectures took place on the one-year
anniversary of September 11th so it's
September 2002 and the assignment was
simply reflect on this with no further
instructions but flesh it out so that
it's 350 minute lectures so that's where
the book came from and sometimes I've
found in the past that actually the
obligation to write a set of lectures is
a pretty good way to write a book
because it forces you to concentrate it
gives you a deadline it even gives you a
structure and knowing that I had three
lectures I am determined in some ways
how I organize how I organize this book
I'm sure now
18th 20th and 21st century palette came
out neater and then I thought it would
actually end I didn't have that in mind
at the beginning but the more I began to
think about this Tamar began to think
about the previous episodes with
surprise attack in American history
one of which obviously is Pearl Harbor
and one of which lesser-known is the
British attack on Washington in 1814 it
just broke down and rather neatly into
19th century 20th century and 21st
century experiences what was 1814 and
why is it little-known 1814 is the tail
end of the war of 1812 which we and the
British blundered into as a kind of
almost after effect of the Napoleonic
Wars in Europe and what happens in
August 1814 is that a British fleet
sails up Chesapeake Bay and they land
and their troops march across and
besiege the city of Washington but not
for very long because the city of
Washington was not at all well defended
under those circumstances the government
flees President Madison and the Capitol
and the White House are burned and this
particularly struck me knowing what we
know about flight 93 which crashed in
Pennsylvania there's been speculation as
to what the targets of that flight were
but the consensus is it was probably one
of those two buildings so in a curious
way we can came full circle with that
surprise attack of 1814 which almost
everybody has forgotten about unless you
listened to the star-spangled banner
which of course was written as if
commemorating that and particularly if
you go beyond the first verse which is
the only one that's ever sung and begin
to go into the second and third verses
you begin to get lurid accounts of how
the Americans felt at this first great
violation of homeland security and it's
probably a good thing that these verses
are not something frequently these days
but they offer a good window into the
mind of Americans at that point and into
the sense of vulnerability and almost
panic that
as a result of that event how many
people were killed
not very many the casualties were quite
small it's nothing like the level of
Pearl Harbor or September 11th and the
British leave the city after a couple of
days they don't occupy the city at all
but it was more the national humiliation
it was more of the sense that here we
had achieved independence from Britain
back some decades earlier and all of a
sudden it's clear that a British fleet
can simply land with impunity March and
destroy burn the national capital that
we had no defenses we had no strategy
and my argument not totally original
with me others have made the same
argument is that that episode forced us
to concentrate on grand strategy and on
national defense really for the first
time because we'd had the luxury of
living apart from the rest of the world
and not having to think very much about
those things and my argument is that the
grand strategy particularly the grand
strategy of John Quincy Adams who was
Secretary of State in the Monroe
administration immediately following and
later himself became president that the
strategy that emerged from this event
really is the first American grand
strategy and one that continued to
inform American policy really all the
way up into well into the 20th century
how long did it take Washington and the
White House and the Capitol to get back
to normal
sometime because the buildings had to be
built rebuilt I mean the White House was
burned to the ground the Capitol was
burned the early Library of Congress was
burned the books many of Jefferson's
books then came here in the aftermath of
that he was still alive yeah sure so it
took a while to rebuild it but
everything happened more slowly and at a
more leisurely pace in the early 19th
century so it is not a matter of there
being a sense of immediate national
crisis or panic to the extent that there
was with Pearl Harbor or with September
11th what there was though
was simply since that the country was
vulnerable the country could not
automatically take security for granted
and it had to have a strategy was there
an 1814 Commission never as far as I
know I mean is there a difference
between what we're doing now and what
they were doing back then is to looking
into this from an intelligence
standpoint to my knowledge there was not
such a commission because in some ways
this was this was a military attack and
of course once the forces land once the
ships sail in Chesapeake Bay you can
pretty well assume they're going to go
for for Washington so there was not the
same there were not the same
investigations of this NIT was not the
same complete bolt out of the blue that
Pearl Harbor and September 11th work but
it was a violation of homeland security
and that I think is the common thread
that links these two things what the
government do what John Quincy Adams do
well what happened was that the Madison
administration leaves office in 1817 the
Monroe administration comes in John
Quincy Adams who is himself in Europe at
the time that these events occur becomes
Secretary of State and it's under Adams
that the thinking that leads to this new
grand strategy begins to emerge and it
has several different dimensions I mean
one was a rapprochement with the British
themselves to try to smooth other over
these differences which was not
difficult to do in the aftermath of the
end of the Napoleonic war in 1815 and
the whole geopolitical situation changes
as a result of thing but another element
was that the sense of insecurity which
had been made manifest on me in August
of 1814 the sense that you can't take
security for granted that stays there
and it's an increasingly important issue
as the American frontier expands and
what Adams confronts shortly after
taking office is a situation in which
raids take place from Florida owned by
Spain at the time across the border into
Georgia Indians escaped slaves and some
British
agents who were playing an ambiguous
role down there General Andrew Jackson
takes his forces crosses the border and
simply wipes them out and doesn't just
retaliate but preempts in the sense of
wiping them out
he was almost cashiered by the Monroe
administration because he acted on his
own without orders from Washington but
it's Adams who comes to his defense and
he comes to his defense and one of the
most famous diplomatic notes of the
early 19th century which is a note to
the Spanish essentially saying you have
a failed state on our border it is the
source of anarchy and insecurity to us
we have the right under these
circumstances to preempt you and
ultimately if you ought to solve this
problem you must either impose order in
that possession of yours or you must
ceded to the United States and this of
course is what in the end in fact fairly
quickly happen so this is the first
American doctrine of preemption that
where insecurity exists along your
borders you have the right to go ahead
and use force to keep that from harming
your security I think it all grows out
of the sense of heightened insecurity
that followed from the original attack
on on Washington it becomes the basis of
the way we dealt with insecurity along
our borders for the next hundred years
or so so it's it's important in that
regard you said that this is a series of
three lectures 50 minutes long at the
New York library but you're a man that I
think lives in New Haven and it teaches
at Yale and the book is published by
Harvard explain how all this came about
well this is less intricate than it
might seem there simply was the
arrangement with the lecture series that
the lectures would become a book that
the book would be published by Harvard
and the arrangement is that whoever
gives these lectures in the future the
book is to be published the books are to
be published by Harvard so there was no
great conspiracy to try to somehow
achieve of meeting him by and with
the Ivy League or something like this on
that that was just the contractual
arrangements for the series how long
have you been yeah I've been a Yale now
for seven years came in 1997 and teach
what all kinds of things to much
I teach Cold War history which is a huge
class at Yale which normally in your
enrolls about five hundred students I
teach grand strategy with my colleagues
Paul Kennedy and Charlie Hill which is a
seminar leadership seminar aimed at
training the next generation of leaders
I teach a course in biography which is
great fun it's a junior seminar in
biography limited to fifteen students
one of my other projects is I am Lee
authorized George Kennan biographer and
have been for some twenty two years now
so I'm interested in biography and have
a great deal of fun teaching this
seminar which consists of really nothing
more complicated than that we read
biographies good ones and bad ones and
talk about what we like and what we
don't like about them how did you become
the authorized George Kennan biographer
that's a very good question
I have who is he by the way George
Kennan of course is the architect of the
American strategy of containment in the
Cold War and perhaps with Henry
Kissinger as one of the two most
influential and grand strategists of the
entire Cold War period for the United
States and as a cold war historian which
I've always been I had in various books
written about Kenan and had interviewed
Kenan in connection with other projects
and after several contacts and after
several kind things that he had said
about books that I had written that had
referred to him the subject came up of a
biography and I asked him if anyone was
doing one he said I think not quite
honestly it had never occurred to me
that anyone would want to do one but now
that you have mentioned it maybe we
should talk about it so there's really a
Boswell Johnson relationship in the
sense that I have access to Kenan to his
papers to all of this have done a lot of
interviews with him but the book is not
to appear in his lifetime and he's
agreed not to read it so I have the
independence of being able to say
whatever I wish to say on this he was 78
when we made this deal he just
celebrated his hundredth birthday so my
relationship with Kenan has gone on
longer than Boswell's relationship with
Johnson why not at this point
why doesn't he he not want to read it
this was something that both of us
concluded although it took us about six
months of delicate negotiation to
realize that we both wanted the same
thing a biographer has got to have
independence you can't write a good
biography if you are constantly worrying
about what the subject of your biography
is going to think about what you're
writing and if you just have this image
of the subject of your biography looking
over your shoulder as you as you write
it's not going to be good and cannon in
his cannons second career after leaving
the State Department was that if
historian who's a profoundly
accomplished historian and he understood
very well without my having to tell it
in the need for this independence on the
part of a biographer and he has
respected that scrupulously all the way
through this long relationship and where
does he live today he lives in Princeton
how's his health he before someone who
is 100 years old pretty good we don't
see him anymore he's mostly at home but
there were a whole series of birthday
celebrations in Princeton back in
February and he did come out and go down
to the Institute for Advanced Study
where he worked for years so he's still
very much in touch with what's going on
before we leave George Kennan give us
just a brief catch for those who may
never have heard of him what is his
legacy in general I would say his legacy
is to have devised the strategy that won
the Cold War basically because this is
the strategy of
if you think about it the idea that one
nation could confront another nation
over as many issues as we confronted the
Soviet Union over as many years as we
did so without having to go to war on
one hand or without caming in and
surrendering on the other I mean the
idea of finding a third way between
these unpleasant extremes has rarely
been done in history indeed it's very
hard to think of any other long term
confrontation between two great nations
that did not either end in appeasement
or in war and it seems to me containment
which is not exclusively kenan signed in
but it was Kenan who best articulated
containment marked out a third path
which was one of building western
defenses particularly with the Marshall
Plan also later with NATO creating a
resilient dynamic West which would
simply be able to hold a line over a
long period of time and take advantage
of the fact that there were a lot of
internal contradictions in the Soviet
system which to Kenan were apparent even
as early as the 1940s that would in the
end cause the emergence of a Soviet
leader who would one day say simply the
system is not working and it has to be
changed so it's almost as if Kenan back
in the late 1940s is anticipating
Gorbachev in the mid-1980s and who did
he work for where he laid out this dress
he was working with in the Truman
administration at this time this is
1946-1947 most famously he was working
with general and George Marshall when
Marshall becomes Secretary of State in
1947 Marshall made cannon the first
director of the policy planning staff at
the State Department and the policy
planning staff under Kenan really turned
out the classic statements of the
containment strategy that are still read
today and still taught today I hope dr.
Kennedy doesn't think this is an
indelicate question but when you first
met him at 878 and you were going to
become his biographer did you think you
were going to have to wait now two years
neither one of us thought that this
relationship would go on as long as it
hasn't it's become the subject of jokes
between us because he regularly calls up
and apologizes for delaying the book
have you got it written no it's not even
written yet because I want to do this
all at one time there are still
documents that are coming out
particularly family documents there were
a lot of other books to write in between
a lot of things have happened like the
end of the Cold War for example so I
have in mind at some wines simply
setting aside two or three years and
writing this all at one time because I
think to be good again a book like this
has to be written all at one time it
cannot just be set aside and then
returned to later on back to your first
lecture which was about the 19th century
and you talk about John Quincy Adams and
we've heard a lot I mean I think George
Bush's father calls him Quincy
there's the parallel between the father
and the son being president but you also
say there's a relationship between what
John Quincy Adams thought and what
George W Bush thinks I think there is in
this sense I don't mean to claim that
George W Bush has been reading up on
John Quincy Adams that's not what I'm
saying
but if you had to characterize the John
Quincy Adams strategy in three words one
of them would be preemption for the
reasons that I mentioned earlier one of
them I think it would be unilateralism
the idea that we don't form binding
alliances with European powers and that
was certainly implied in the Monroe
Doctrine which is Adams doctrine and one
is hegemony which Adam has meant
hegemony over the North American
continent was that word mean
it simply means we are going to be more
powerful than anybody else to put it in
the terms that the Bush administration
uses now strength beyond challenge and
this was very much Adams aspiration for
the United States within the North
American continent that we would not
welcome the creation of a balance of
power on the North American continent of
the kind that had nominated Europe for
so long because that led to Wars and
catastrophe and swim so Adams had very
much the view that the United States
must be the dominant power on the North
American continent and being on Adams he
lays this out most clearly in a letter
to his mom Abigail in 1811 working dear
mother the United States must dominate
the North American continent and this
was the nature of the Adams family that
questions of grand strategy were
discussed in this way among them where
does this strategy come from that we're
living through today the strategy today
it seems to me comes from several
different things it obviously comes from
the shock of September 11th which called
into question the strategy that won the
Cold War the strategy of containment and
deterrence and the Bush administration
has been quite explicit in saying while
these ideas are not dead those
techniques are still applicable they are
not enough we must have the capacity to
preempt those who would launch attacks
of the kind of took place on September
11 so it comes partially out of a sense
of shock and surprise which is not in
its own way surprising because I think
that's where grant strategies tend to
emerge that's what I'm arguing about the
quincy adams strategy coming out of the
shock of 1814 and surely the franklin
roosevelt strategy of building alliance
is working within coalition's but
projecting really a global reach of
power comes out of the shock of Pearl
Harbor in 1941 so I think surprises like
this give rise or tend to give rise to
new grand strategies when these things
tend to happen I think that there is
sometimes an almost automatic or
unthinking instinct to look back or to
feel back and it's more of a matter of
feeling and looking to feel what is the
American character what has been the
American response in periods of crisis
and one of the things I'm trying to
argue is that the American response to
surprise attack is not to run and hide
the American response
generally is to expand the sphere of
interests and the sphere of
responsibilities rather than to contract
them so just as we expanded those
spheres of responsibility to include the
whole North American continent in the
aftermath of the war of 1812 so we do
this on a global scale in the aftermath
of Pearl Harbor to the extent of
building coalitions and alliances that
could defeat the authoritarians the
fascists first and then later the Soviet
Union and its allies in the Cold War now
we have it extended it further because
the Bush Doctrine no longer is content
with simply building balances of power
or building coalitions but it's just
saying we actually have to intervene in
the internal affairs of certain states
where those states may be breeding
terrorists so this goes beyond
sovereignty into something new it is
really to make the assertion that the
internal situation in a country halfway
around the world from us and seemingly
extremely remote from us can produce a
situation of which creates the most
vital are the most dangerous prospects
for American security and of course
that's what happened with Afghanistan of
all places where the Taliban and Osama
bin Laden cooked up this attack have you
ever met George Bush I have not met the
current George Bush I have met the other
George Bush where do you find yourself
looking at this from your own vantage
point saying is this a good idea what
he's doing I think the strategy itself
which was most clearly laid out in the
national strategy statement of September
2002 makes a lot of sense because I do
take very seriously the new kind of
danger that confronts us the fact that
just this small gang starting from caves
in Afghanistan were able to organize an
attack that did so much damage that
killed more people than Pearl Harbor did
indicates a new kind of vulnerability
that not just we but the entire world
now
in front whether from weapons of mass
destruction or what we saw in September
11th which was just instruments of
conventional life used for the purpose
of mass destruction box cutters and
airplanes I think that's a new situation
which really does require a new strategy
and I think there's little question that
where you confront that kind of danger
preemption is the option that you have
to think about I don't think this means
a repudiation of containment and
deterrence and the bush strategy
statement has been pretty explicit on
that that you still want to practice
those strategies when you're dealing
with States but the problem is states
are no longer the only problem we faced
and non-state actors gangs are the
problem as well and to try to contain
someone who is invisible or to try to
deter somebody who is prepared to commit
suicide doesn't make much sense so
something more is needed and that's been
the argument of the administration in
your book you suggest that the foreign
policy of Bill Clinton was like Coolidge
or Harding well yes in the sense that
like Coolidge and Harding the Clinton
administration was a post war
administration Harding and Coolidge of
course in power in the immediate
aftermath of World War one seemingly a
great victory for the United States
Clinton and power in the immediate
aftermath of the end of the Cold War and
as there was a sense in both decades the
1920s and the 1990s that we did not
confront any serious security threats
because our great enemies had been
vanquished in the in the wars that were
just over there was a sense that history
was on our side that historical trends
were moving in directions favorable to
us and that you could take a relatively
relaxed view of national security which
certainly Harding and Coolidge did and I
think Clinton did too certainly in the
early first term and some extent in the
second term the assumption simply that
the
you're reversible global trends that are
out there are toward the democratization
of the world toward the marketization of
the world the world is now safe both for
democracy and capitalism and therefore
you can focus on domestic issues you can
focus on humanitarian issues but
national security is not a huge threat I
think that was the idea that was out
there by the time Clinton left office
there had been enough terrorist attacks
there had been the first attack on the
World Trade Center in 1993 they've been
Khobar towers in 1996 have been the
attack on the cult in 2000 that this was
beginning to be rethought and it was
Bill Clinton who authorized the heart
Rudman Commission this is the national
commission chaired by former senators
Warren Rudman and Gary Hart which began
its work back in the late 90s and
actually came up with the best
prediction of what was going to happen
in their final report which was
published in March of 2001 saying that
we were indeed vulnerable to this kind
of attack so I don't say the Clinton
administration was totally asleep at the
switch or complacent on this but I do
say that their chief priority
particularly in the first administration
was domestic I do say that there was no
grand strategy that emerged in the
Clinton administration that would
address these kinds of issues that now
preoccupies and I would also say that's
not very surprising because there was no
great shock to generate such a grand
strategy and of course he had required
the shock of Pearl Harbor to generate
that back in the 1940s we went through
the Harding Coolidge Hoover and first to
Roosevelt terms without really
rethinking the situation that confronted
us then which was that new developments
in naval and air technology meant that
oceans were no longer we could no longer
count on oceans and distance for
protection and it was not until that
became clear at Pearl Harbor that we
really began to focus on the
implications of that so there's an
analogy there I think to September 11 in
that heart Redmond report
mm-hm in the early part of 2001 this was
before September the 11th their first
recommendation I murmured correctly is
to create a department of homeland
security that's right how often in our
past have we had people predict what's
going to happen and they I think they
also predicted about possibly airplanes
flying into buildings they didn't
specifically predict airplanes flying
into buildings as I recall it but what
they did say is that we face the danger
of attacks on American soil that could
produce casualties in the thousands or
even tens of thousands they said that
this could happen over the next 25 years
they did not say it's gonna happen
within the next four months or five
months so it was a general warning it
was not a specific warning but it
certainly was a sufficient warning that
I think there was plenty of good reason
to take it very seriously whether that
would have happened whether it would
have been taken seriously whether the
bush administration really would have
come up with a strategy in response to
this or really would have created a
department of homeland security and the
absence of the September 11 attack I'm
not at all sure remember the Bush
administration actually for a while
opposed the idea of a Department of
Homeland Security I had to be persuaded
that this was necessary so there was a
degree of complacency there too I think
this is quite natural because part of
the problem here is that it's awfully
difficult for anybody to anticipate
something that has never before happened
and that's what September 11th was just
as Pearl Harbor also was nothing like
that had ever happened before nobody had
ever used aircraft carriers and fighter
planes to launch a long-range attack of
the kind that the Japanese did at Pearl
Harbor nobody could ever use airplanes
and box cutters to fly them into
buildings before September 11 so I don't
fault people for in either
administration for not foreseeing this
specific thing because it's almost
impossible to foresee something that has
never happened before you mentioned
earlier Boswell and Johnson who was
Samuel Johnson
all time he'll Johnson was the great he
could put it the great man of English
letters in the late 18th century the
author of Johnson's great dictionary
critic of plays and the most wonderful
conversationalist apparently of his age
although much of what we know about
those conversations comes from James
Boswell who simply followed him around
and took notes for a period of 20 years
or so and then wound up writing the
first great biography in Western
literature his life of Johnson so that
was that's the classic relationship
between a biographer and the subject of
a bag you have a quote in the book from
Samuel Johnson I got the impression as I
was reading that you enjoyed putting
this quote in there and I'll read it
this is Samuel Johnson quote depend on
it sir when a man knows that he is to be
hanged in a fortnight it concentrates
his mind wonderfully and I think that's
a good strategic principle because it
illustrates what I was saying about
Minds not concentrating when there does
not seem to be a clear threat but the
presence of a threat the existence of a
clear and present danger does tend to
concentrate Minds I don't think it even
has to be a surprise attack for that to
happen there was no surprise attack in
the aftermath of World War two and yet
the clear and present danger that was
posed by the Soviet Union and where the
Soviet Union wound up at the end of
World War two in occupation of half of
Europe was a sufficient motive for
concentrating minds that a very creative
period in American grand strategy
emerged from that the doctrine of
containment the doctrine of the Marshall
Plan NATO so it takes a crisis sometimes
to concentrate minds it's very hard to
get minds to concentrate when things
seem to be normal and that's unfortunate
and it can be dangerous but I think it's
a fact of life
you write and mention a lot about
historians
the book who are historians that you
read all the time who are the ones that
have made the biggest impact on you hmm
that's a good question I would say the
great classical historians have been
very much influenced certainly by Gibbon
and the rise and fall of the Roman
Empire but I partly become interested in
given because Kenan was so influenced by
Gibbon Kenan would say that the single
greatest influence on his life
was reading the decline and fall of the
Roman Empire as a foreign service
officer in World War two having to fly
across the Atlantic it took 24 hours to
fly across the Atlantic and back in
those days you had to have something big
to read and so he brought the decline
and fall of the Roman Empire this very
much shaped his thinking about strategy
my own thinking is very much shaped in
part by the books that we read in the
course that I teach at Yale with my
colleagues Paul Kennedy and Charlie Hill
which are the great classics of grand
strategies so acidities in the
Peloponnesian War has an enormous
influence and not just on thinking about
strategy but thinking about history as
well
certainly for us Machiavelli in not a
historian surely is important in terms
of Helen thinks about history perhaps
for me most most influential has been
has wits and his great book on war which
is a complicated dense and uncompleted
work which nonetheless offers all kinds
of rewards every time I go back to it
and particularly every time I teach it I
will have a student who will see
something different in it that I haven't
seen before so it's an endlessly
fruitful but to keep coming back to in
this regard
certainly Kissinger on matter net
Kissinger's world restored which he
wrote as a young man in the 1950s
about the aftermath of the Napoleonic
war has been extremely influential with
me and how I think about the balance of
power but more particularly how I think
about statecraft in general as well as
being a wonderful guide to Kissinger
zone performance as a statesman when he
came into that capacity in the 1970s
where did you originally get interested
in even getting into this profession
well as a graduate student in Texas in
1960s the University of Texas in Austin
after having failed to be good at a lot
of other things like pre-med like
running the ranch like running the
drugstore in a small town like not at
all being interested in being a
librarian which is what my mom wanted me
to do and like simply having taken a
fair number of history courses and
decided that was the only thing left and
then having one professor at a critical
moment senior year of college University
of Texas yeah call me in and say the
paper you have written for me which was
actually on Elizabethan England's trade
with Russia in the 16th century it had
nothing to do with color this paper
could be published and I never published
it but the fact that he called me in and
said that made me decide to go to
graduate school
oh is his name his name was Stan Limburg
and he taught Tudor history and is still
around I believe in the University of
Minnesota now and where did you go to
the grads because it was too late to
apply anywhere else I just stayed right
there
and went all the way through at Texas
get your PhD there I did and what was
your dissertation the dissertation
actually turned out to be on the origins
of the Cold War and this was the late
1960s and this was the period when the
American documents on the beginning of
the Cold War we're just beginning to be
Declassified at that point and I knew
that I wanted to work on something where
I was going to have a steady flow of
fresh documents along the way I knew I
didn't want to do something that other
historians had
exhausted and it seemed a pretty good
bet that the Cold War was going to be a
major topic and that we would continue
to have documents coming available so it
really dealt with the 1941 to 1947
period the origins of the Cold War an
extent to which the origins of the Cold
War were embedded in the diplomacy of
World War two and then I'd been doing
Cold War history
off and on for ever since and where were
you you've been Yale for seven years
where were you before that I was most of
almost all of this time at Ohio
University in Athens Ohio a wonderful
not very widely known place I was there
for 28 years teaching history with a
generous leave policy on the part of
that university that allowed me to go to
several other interesting places for a
year or two years at a time so two years
teaching at the u.s. Naval War College
in the 1970s an extraordinarily
important experience for me in terms of
getting interested in in strategy as
well as diplomatic history you're
teaching at the University of Helsinki
in the early 80s semester at Princeton
two semesters at two years at Oxford so
there have been opportunities to go off
and teach and sample other places along
the way but I was really quite happy at
Ohio for a long time and it's just out
of the blue Yale called up and that
seemed like a good idea so I've been
here ever since
go to the current situation they call it
the Bush Doctrine or the grand strategy
of today who do you think is the
architect of it and how much did history
play in the decision as to what we're
doing right now in the world I think
there are several architects of the bush
grand strategy and I would surely name
the people who are almost often in Paul
Wolfowitz Richard Perle
in this regard I would say that you can
see the elements of the current Bush
grand strategy in the first Bush
administration just beginning to show up
there was the famous wolf
defense posture statement of 1991 or
1992 which laid out some of these ideas
that now that the Cold War is over the
United States must maintain strength
beyond challenge but none of this was
taken terribly seriously and certainly
none of it became the basis for a
coherent brand strategy
it seems to me until the events of
September 11th my sources in the
administration tell me that they already
had in the works a statement of grand
strategy because such statements are
actually mandated by law the
goldwater-nichols Act going back to 1986
mandates that the administration's
report on national security strategy but
this has been very much of perfunctory
exercise until this administration and
they had such a report under way that
was going to try to move in new
directions but it was just under way and
then they were hit with September 11 so
that was an extremely powerful impetus
to pull the new strategy together will
we someday like you are with George
Cannon be studying Paul Wolfowitz
I think only indirectly because I don't
think Paul Wolfowitz had the same
dominant influence on the shaping of
this strategy that's where some of the
ideas start but other people were
influential as well and in the actual
preparation of the strategy condi rice
was quite important because it was
happening under her direction as well
two things you met well one thing you
mentioned one you're right about one is
the doctrine of preemption yeah and the
other one is access of evil as we we
think we know that David Frum wrote
those words you don't I don't think you
like that phrase well it seems to me
that the national strategy statement
that came out in September of 2002
talking about the need to deal with both
terrorists and tyrants putting them on
an equal basis articulating the doctrine
of preemption showing how that related
to containment and deterrence and
aligning all of this with a long-term
strategy of trying to address the causes
of terrorism by actually promoting
democracy
throughout the world that was the
essence of the September 2002 document
I think the axis of evil speech got off
track I think the axis of evil speech
confused the issue because it seemed to
lump North Korea and Iran and Iraq all
together when in fact the policy of the
administration has been to have really
quite different policies toward these
three countries we've been negotiating
with Iran and in some cases cooperating
with Iran on intelligence matters as
we've been surly seeking to contain but
not preempt North Korea and then we
preempted in Iraq we preempted Saddam
Hussein so it seems to me these were
very different approaches to these
countries and I think the axis of evil
idea was simply not a serious idea I
think it was a speech writer who got out
of control that happens how often and
we're in the middle of a presidential
campaign how often coming at it from
historic historians tempo do you hear
people supporting presidents and
candidates just because they're loyal to
them and they're in that party when
those people really aren't leading from
the traditional positions you would
think a conservative would be an a
Republican or a Democrat I think there's
some of that I think this happens it
seems to me that the party lines and
particularly the idea of what is a
liberal and what is a conservative now
in foreign policy has become blurred if
you were just to explain to a man for
more from Mars what kind of a policy
would it be to say that the United
States must literally seek to make the
world safe for democracy you would say
that's wilsonian liberalism right but
it's also Bush neoconservatism right now
and the neoconservatives are drawing on
the role of idea ideas and ideals
they're drawing on the Wilsonian legacy
this is no new thing this really began
to happen I think with Ronald Reagan who
was taking conservatism in the direction
of moving just beyond cold-blooded
realism but looking at the role of ideas
the importance of
Human Rights the importance of pushing
democracy even in areas that had
previously been thought in us hospitable
to it like Eastern Europe like the
Soviet Union so the current Bush
administration is very much in this
Reagan tradition and the Reagan
tradition has been one of moving
conservatism in Wilsonian directions and
in the process this has scooped up a lot
of people who started out as Democrats
but who have many of the
neoconservatives actually started out as
Henry Jackson Democrats who've come now
you know and some still consider
themselves Democrats but they are very
much more aligned with the Republican
Party in terms of where it is today than
they are with the Democratic Party if
the president called you to the Oval
Office and said professor I know you've
looked at history what mistakes can I
make right now that'll mess all this up
what would you tell him well I think
they're making some in Iraq right now I
mean it seems to me that the strategy
the overall strategy made a lot of sense
and I supported the decision to go into
Iraq but it seems to me there was a lot
more planning of the military exercise
how do you take Iraq then there was the
question what do you do with it once you
have it and I think their performance
there has been really quite ragged I
think their performance on
multilateralism has been ineffective
they themselves said in the national
strategy statement that if this
preemption doctrine is going to work
it's got to have multilateral support it
can't be a unilateral act by the United
States unilateralism is only a last
resort they said and yet very quickly we
moved into what was virtually a
unilateral pre-emptive act and of course
they ran into a lot of difficulties with
the French and others in the UN they
also let themselves get locked into a
pretty rigid timetable I think where
they felt they had to move by a certain
date and that closed off giving more
time to the inspectors that closed off
giving more time for diplomacy to work
we were paying the price
that to a considerable extent now I
think what I would say is basically two
things one is to acknowledge some
mistakes and it strikes me that one of
the things this administration finds it
most difficult to do is to acknowledge
mistakes great strategists in the past
have done this Churchill did it
Roosevelt did it to acknowledge a
mistake is to leave one optimistic that
the problem might be fixed to fail to
acknowledge mistake leaves one rather
pessimistic because it might appear that
the administration is not aware that
there is a problem and there are some so
I think admitting mistakes would be a
place to start the second thing I would
say is that whatever you may think of
the decision to go into Iraq the
situation that confronts us now provides
the opportunity for a multilateral
consensus because I don't know anybody
who wants us to fail in Iraq at this
point at least anybody among the great
powers among our allies the only people
who want us to fail are the terrorists
themselves but on this point there is
clearly a consensus among French and the
Germans in the Spanish that were we to
pull out now or were we to be forced out
this would be a disaster John Kerry says
the same thing that offers to the basis
I think for a consensus it offers the
basis for a new approach in which the
United States could admit that some
errors have been made but it could also
stress the point that a an enormous
common interest exists out there and
really that the opportunity does Ignace
to move back to the multilateral concept
which the administration itself talked
about and its own strategy statement two
years ago we had in the 21st century in
your a lecture at the New York Library
by the way how bigger crowded yeah oh
there were a couple of hundred people
and they were they all come to each one
and well some came to all three and
others came in and out and when did you
give these these were back in September
of 2002
you talked about how democracies don't
have control of the movement of people
anymore like they used to any list cheap
air travel liberal immigration policy
fax machines cell phones satellite
television transmitters and and the
internet let's talk a little more about
that well all I was trying to say here
was that the things that we often
consider to be good things and they are
in many ways almost always will have
some downsides and this is true of
things like self-determination that's a
great idea
but of course self-determination is
practiced in former Yugoslavia led to
horrendous violence as that state began
to break up in the early 1990s we tend
to think of globalization as a great
idea but globalization has plenty of
downsides because it leaves so many
people behind and what I meant in this
case was that the open society which we
all applaud our ability to cross borders
and communicate freely and to be able to
fax and email messages and so on around
the world which we value a great deal
has also had a down side because the
terrorists of September 11 took
advantage of this easy access to this
country they took advantage of the
ability to move money easily around
without controls they certainly took
advantage of liberal immigration
policies they took advantage of the
internet and email so there's nothing
new in this whenever progress occurs
there is going to be a downside the
invention of the automobile was progress
but the downside was people killed each
other in automobiles so I think anybody
thinking about long term trends has got
to get beyond just the romantic
assumption that these are automatically
and in all respects going to be good
because there will be downsides to them
and this is one area where it seems to
me we could think ahead and try to
foresee what those downsides might be to
a greater extent than we have you know a
lot about George Kennan and how
thinks now and obviously you studied a
lot about FDR if those two men were in
control today given what you know about
them what would be different
well FDR was an extremely capable but
deceptive strategist because FDR was no
intellect FDR made C's at Harvard FDR
was said to have a flypaper of mind
which was incapable of focusing on
anything any more than about two minutes
FDR gave conflicting instructions to his
advisors and often had them working at
odds with each other from an
administrative management point of view
his running of the presidency and
particularly of American grand strategy
looks chaotic and yet as the British
historian AJP Taylor said at one point
of the three Great World War two leaders
Churchill Roosevelt and Stalin Roosevelt
was the only one who knew what he was
doing because he made the u.s. the
greatest power in the world at almost no
cost and certainly at very little cost
compared to the costs that the other
great powers had to pay in World War two
is George W Bush that kind of
strategists I don't know it's too early
to say I think his performance in the
immediate aftermath of September 11th
the decision to go into Afghanistan
which was an astonishing decision at the
time because Afghanistan was supposed to
be the graveyard of invaders this had
happened to the British twice and to the
Russians so this was an enormous Lee
courageous decision to go into
Afghanistan and that was successful in
terms of what it was intended to do I
think the speed with which the
administration came up with the new
strategy and the sweep and scope of the
new strategy the fact that the new
strategy addresses both short-term
concerns and long-term concerns was
impressive at the same time it seems to
me that more recently and particularly
in dealing with the crisis that has
developed in a
the bush leadership has been a good deal
less effectual I just don't see Bush
leaning in the way that it seems to mean
he should be doing I think he should be
saying this is going to be tough this is
going to require sacrifices this is
going to require reassessing the things
that have gone wrong and trying to fix
them it's going to require trying to
rebuild relationships with allies and
with other great powers it's going to
require the specification of an end
point of what does this strategy
actually lead to to whom do we transfer
power in Iraq and how does it how do we
sustain it at a time when the American
military are stretched terribly terribly
thin these are things that are not being
discussed I think that it's not a matter
of the overall strategy being down the
tubes by any means I think that the
overall strategy makes a lot of sense
and I think if John Kerry becomes
president next November he will have to
acknowledge this and we'll probably find
himself confronting some of the same
realities that inform the bush grand
strategy I think the bush failings are
more in the area of the immediate Iraq
situation how they've handled that the
failure to find the weapons of mass
destruction the fudging of intelligence
that I don't doubt did take place to
some extent the failure to have a clear
plan for what we do on the ground the
failure to acknowledge these errors to a
greater extent these I think are the
failings this is the cover of the book
small book 150 pages three lectures
surprise security and the American
experience John Lewis Gaddis professor
at Yale we thank you very much thank you
sir